new government data shows the US economy
is gaining momentum the economy grew 2.9
percent in the fourth quarter of 2017
that caps the strongest nine-month
stretch in more than 12 years David
Rubenstein his co-founder and C & Co
executive chairman of the Carlyle Group
one of the world's largest private
equity firms his firm manages a total of
195 billion dollars with a B across 317
investment vehicles all around the world
before getting into business you should
know he served in President Jimmy
Carter's administration David welcome my
pleasure to be here it's always good to
see you what we'll talk about business
in a second but I am curious about your
thoughts about you know business you
know politics you've been in the White
House what is your take on what's
happening in Washington these days from
the business point of view in a
political point of view well the
business community I think is generally
satisfied that the tax cuts have gone
through the business community is
pleased with those generally and
obviously there are some things that
they would prefer to be different than
came out in the final bill but generally
I think people in the business community
were happy with the tax cuts they
wouldn't be the tax cuts that I might
have proposed myself I think it was
probably more favorable to people in my
income bracket then than everybody I
think we do have an income inequality
problem and a social mobility problem
that bill wasn't designed to deal with
that but I think generally the economy's
in reasonable shape it's what I call
global synchronous happiness everybody's
happy right now should we worry when
everybody's happy well that's the big
concern when everybody's happy you have
to be worried because when things look
perfect sometimes they don't turn out to
be that way so sometimes there's going
to be something hidden a bit I don't
think there's a Cheatham behind me or
something but there's no doubt that
there's something lurking behind us now
we've had about 104 straight months of
economic growth that's the third large
the longest in our history at some point
the economic cycle will go down I don't
know if we're prepared for it yet my
biggest worries about the economy are
these while I think it's in very good
shape now and I think we'll have
probably two and a half percent growth
this year low unemployment low inflation
at some point it will end when it ends I
want to make sure we're prepared for it
I do worry about the amount of debt we
have we have 21 trillion dollars of
federal debt that's a lot of debt I do
worry about the income inequality
problem it's getting worse
social mobility is getting worse and I
do worry about another problem we
haven't talked
a lot which is literacy people in our
country are not able to read very much
14% of our people in our country adults
are functionally illiterate they can't
read beyond the fourth grade level if
you have increasing percentage of high
illiteracy you're not gonna be I'll ever
solve this income inequality problem so
it's something we really need to work on
The Carlyle Group has investments in in
China are you worried about a potential
trade war with China I'm not because I
think the relationship is so strong that
I don't think we're gonna really have a
trade war it's not in anybody's interest
so there have been some disputes on
tariffs and so forth but I don't think
it's gonna set up set this enormous
relationship we are gigantic investor in
China will continue to be a gigantic
investor in China it's the biggest
economy in the world by purchase price
parity measurement and by GDP it will be
in our lifetime the biggest economy in
the world so if you're an investor in
the global economic world you really
should be in China gotta be yeah the
Chinese President Xi Jinping has
consolidated power there our biggest
threat the United States biggest threat
they there's been a lot of talk though
that there might be retaliation on this
trade front well first I don't think
they're our biggest threat you might say
economically but our biggest threat
really I think comes from Russia or from
global terrorism that's our biggest
threat but in terms of China is an
economic power yes they are competing
with us but Gigi ping has done a pretty
good job I think of working with
President Trump I think they figured out
how to have a reasonably good
relationship and I think Xi Jinping's
relationship with the Korean North
Korean president seemed to have done
wonders in terms of getting the thing
moving forward I don't know why we are
able to have a discussion with North
Korea as it appears we will be able to
but if we do come together and have a
talk with North Korea between the
president and the head of North Korea I
do think that will be a positive thing
and I think trying to deserve some
credit for that you look at the front
page of the Financial Times day and it
talks about of course the fangs the tech
stocks all dropping are we having a
reckoning now in terms of this there's
no doubt that our economy is very
influenced now by these large technology
companies and when you ever have so much
power there is going to be some
reverberation but the interesting thing
about that these are American companies
and they may think that's been
interesting to me is that no company
outside the United States has really
been able to build this kind of global
technology presence so I think it's very
good for us and we're able to do this
there is obviously some concern in
Europe and China about the impact
these companies on their economies and
their culture but right now as Americans
I think they're pretty good for us what
do you think of the president's choice
of larry cudlow is this top economic
advisor you you've said you think
generally the team is good it's not
Alexander Hamilton you said probably not
but generally it's good well Alexander
Hamilton had the advantage of liking a
play written about him and I don't know
if Larry Kudlow is going to play written
about it but maybe he does he'll regard
it as well Larry Kudlow is obviously a
very experienced person he worked in the
Reagan administration he knows the
Washington quite well so I think he
deserves a very good chance to show what
he can do these are not easy jobs in the
White House this is a job that didn't
exist when I was there they didn't have
a national economic coordinator that
didn't start until a president President
Clinton when Bob Rubin invented a job
more or less it's a tough job but I
think Larry Kudlow is well-prepared for
it well David Shulkin is as you know is
no longer there and he's not going
quietly so the environment in Washington
is toxic chaotic disrespectful and
subversive do you think that that's an
accurate take you know you're somebody
that has bipartisan dinners with members
of Congress would you agree with his
assessment of how it's working in
Washington these days if I had just lost
my job I might say that as well but I
think it's just sour grapes David do you
well I don't know if it's sour grapes I
don't know him so I can't really say I
would just say right now the atmosphere
in Washington is not what it was when I
was there in the 60s and the 70s at that
point people from the Democratic side
and Republican side did work together
try to get bipartisan legislation that
rarely happens today I've started a
series of dinners to try to bring
Democrats and Republicans at down
together talking about American history
of things we can agree on a eat well
together they do and they actually like
to sit with each other there's no press
there so nobody can see that they're
actually sitting and talking to each
other from people in the opposite party
but I do think there is a desire on part
of Democrats and Republicans to come
together but obviously the atmosphere
right now doesn't lend itself to that
the President to those dinners well
these are for members of Congress but
I'm sure if the president wanted to come
I'm sure he'd be welcome Rubin say all
right so much thank you my pleasure
morning thank you